[موسيقى]
دمر هذا الجيش البنيه التحتيه وقد انشا
هذا الحاجز لمنع المواطنين في مدينه بيت
حانون الى
الوصول الى قلب مدينه بيت
حانون
هذا هو مدخل شارع الجرمان الذي استهدفته
طائرات الاحتلال وشنت عليه الحزام الناري
القوي العنيف في مدينه بيت حانون لم يبقى
في بيت حانون حجرا على حجر كل شيء في بيت
حانون هو عباره عن ركام هو عباره عن دمار
لا يوجد اي بيت صالح للسكن في هذه المنطقه
هنا عاد المواطنين اليوم الى ديارهم في
مدينه بيت حانون لكن فوجئوا باطلاق عدد
كبير من النيران باتجاههم يعني العدو الان
متمركز وسط مدينه بيت حانون يحاول منع
المواطنين الوصول الى بيوتهم قد ارتقوا
عددا كبيرا من الشهداء بسبب استهداف من
قبل قناصه العدو واسر عدد كبير من
المواطنين الذين كانوا ذاهبين الى
بيوتهم